Hey, do you have a favorite reality show?
Oh come on, don't lie, everyone has one.
Dr. Clef loves some American Ninja Warrior,
and I’ve got it on good authority that Dr.
Bright can’t get enough of The Bachelor,
so how about you, huh?
Do you obsessively follow the romantic highs
and lows of Love Island, or are you more the
type who likes to curl up with a mug of hot
cocoa and enjoy a nice, wholesome episode
of The Great British Baking Show?
Do you ever yell at the TV when the contestants
on Jeopardy just can't get the answer right?
Do you get a kick out of seeing what crazy
collectibles will show up on this week's episode
of Pawn Stars?
If you answered yes to any of these, you're
not alone - Millions of people around the
world still tune in to all kinds of reality
TV.
Personally, I just can't get enough of my
favorite hidden camera show: Laugh is Fun.
What's that?
You've never heard of Laugh is Fun?
Oh, boy.
You're really missing out.
If you like reality TV, you're gonna love
Laugh is Fun.
Laugh is Fun, also known as SCP-2030, isn't
a show that you can watch on TV.
Instead, it appears as the most popular form
of media distribution in the current year.
Today, you can find it on file-sharing and
streaming websites, but in the 2000's, you
could rent it from the DVD kiosk at the mall,
and back in the ‘90s, it used to show up
as multi-tape sets in video rental stores.
Even though the SCP foundation has only been
aware of Laugh is Fun since 1993, it has a
recorded 38 seasons as of 2014, meaning that
it may have existed in some form as far back
as the 1970s.
If you want to binge all 38 seasons, you might
also want to look it up under the names Laugh
is Life, or, in some countries, Laugh is Laugh.
And if you happen to be in a country where
Laugh is Laugh isn’t available, you may
want to try changing your location using a
VPN to one where you can access it… oh,
what’s that?
You don’t HAVE a VPN service?
Well then I’m glad you’re here, because
before we go any further I have a very important
word from our sponsor who just so happens
to be NordVPN, the preferred VPN service of
all the researchers here at SCP Explained,
sign up now at nordvpn.com/SCPExplained .
NordVPN isn’t just a VPN, it’s truly the
BEST VPN available.
With a simple click, you’ll be able access
content that might be blocked just because
of your location, so you’ll never have to
miss an episode of your favorite anomalous
television programs.
But wait, there’s more, much, much more!
What if you’re right in the middle of binge
watch of Season 31 when suddenly your quality
dips to looking like a couple of blurry blocks
are fighting over an old shoebox.
Never fear, because NordVPN encrypts ALL your
traffic.
That means your internet service provider
can’t throttle your service and slow down
your streaming speed.
You should never settle for less than the
highest quality pixels after all.
And it doesn’t matter how you choose to
watch, NordVPN is available on every modern
platform including Windows, iOS, Android,
macOS, Linux, and even Android TV.
The monthly cost is the same as a cup of coffee,
regular coffee that is, not the kind that
comes from SCP-294, and if you sign up by
going to nordvpn.com/SCPExplained you’ll
even get a free month!
So go try it for yourself right now, that’s
nordvpn.com/SCPexplained
Now, back to your regularly scheduled programming.
As we were saying,
Laugh is Fun is a prank show that puts unknowing
everyday people into ridiculous scenarios
and films their reactions.
Each episode is about 10 to 12 minutes long
and features an opening and closing monologue
from beloved, supposedly human TV presenter
Laughy McLaugherson, aka SCP-2030-1.
You've probably seen him before, he's never
seen without his blue three-piece suit and
black wing-tipped shoes.
Funniest guy on TV, seriously, I think he
should replace James Corden on the Late Late
Show.
And maybe even take up a hosting gig on SNL,
if he’s still got time after.
He had this amazing monologue at the end of
an episode in season 32.
“Ha!
What a ride, eh, folks?
We've seen printers that eat, eaters that
print, and everything in between!
Makes you appreciate the old clunker you have
back the office, doesn't it?
No, printers may not always work when you
want or need them to, but they sure make for
some excellent comedy.
And that's what we're about here: comedy.
We're here to make you laugh.
We hope you laughed.
Thank you for laughing with us.
That's what we're about here, doesn't it,
folks?
Come laugh with us again next time!
And remember: LAUGH … IS … FUN!
Good night!
And laugh!
Just laugh!
We love the make laugh.
Make more for laughter so as to for laugh.
Laugh with us.
Laugh with us!
Laugh!
Laugh and let us in!”
Hmmm.
I couldn't tell you what his face looks like,
though, because he's always framed from the
neck down.
Once the pranks are done for the episode,
he'll step up on that bright yellow stage
and deliver his closing monologue, which always
ends with a pan over the audience as everyone
chants “Laugh with us!”
Then the show always just cuts to black.
The closest thing the show ever has to credits
is a title card that says “Filmed in front
of a studio audience in partnership with YWTGTHFT.”
For a show that doesn't advertise or even
air on TV, Laugh is Fun is still a beloved
classic, and when you watch it, it's easy
to see why it's been around so long.
Laughy and the team pull off some really classic
pranks on Laugh is Laugh!
There's this one episode in season 13, where
an unsuspecting family is sitting down to
dinner.
The father starts choking, and the family
reacts with horror, until suddenly a pair
of slits appear on the father's neck, allowing
him to breathe.
Those slits soon become nostrils, and before
you know it, a full second head grows out
of his neck.
That head then grows its own neck, which grows
a nose, then a face, then another head, then
another neck.
This keeps happening a total of 18 times while
the rest of the family looks on in horror.
But don't worry, before things go too far,
Laughy pops out from under the table and tells
the family that they're on Laugh is Fun.
Laughy points out the cameras, and the whole
family starts laughing, including all 18 of
the father's heads.
There's another great season 13 episode called
“Squirrels.”
Oh, man, that one had me in stitches!
Alright, so there's this couple lying in bed,
and the wife wakes up because she hears this
squeaking noise.
She taps her husband on the shoulder to wake
him up, but she draws her hand back in horror
because she can feel something moving under
her husband's skin.
Before she can ask if he's okay, boom!
Hundreds of squirrels explode out of his skin
and start running around the room while the
wife screams.
Then Laughy walks in and turns the lights
on, accompanied by the husband, who is perfectly
okay even though he's been skinned from head
to toe.
Everyone laughs.
Then there's a more recent episode from season
24, called “Swelling.”
There's this old lady sitting on a park bench,
feeding the pigeons, and a couple walks past
her.
While they walk past, the old lady gets swarmed
by the pigeons she's feeding.
The pigeons force themselves into her mouth
and keep swarming until her stomach cavity
bursts open.
The couple, who get sprayed with guts as all
the pigeons fly off, are extremely distressed
by this until Laughy shows up.
Some people say that this episode is too similar
to Squirrels and that the show was starting
to get stale at this point, but I think the
joke is unique enough to stand on its own.
Plus, with a prank show as long-running as
Laugh, it's inevitable that you're gonna see
some jokes get reused.
Really, it's not about the prank itself, it's
about the reactions of the people, which are
always priceless!
And man, the way that Laughy McLaugherson
comes into the frame by climbing out of the
old lady's open ribcage?
I was rolling on the floor!
Oh, you don't think the old “animals exploding
out of people” bit is funny?
That's fair enough.
Let me think - what are some of my other favorite
episodes of Laugh is Fun?
Oh - the Margaret Thatcher episode from season
21!
That's another great thing about Laugh is
Fun, it's not afraid to get a little political.
So, this woman walks into her kitchen and
opens the cabinet, but instead of food being
in there, it's just a big blob of flesh.
The flesh blob rolls out onto the counter
and morphs into a misshapen caricature of
Margaret Thatcher with a disproportionately
big head.
The woman starts screaming, but the Thatcher
creature jumps onto her, pinning her down
and shoving its tongue into her mouth.
The deeper the tongue goes, the more Margaret
Thatcher faces start appearing all over the
woman's skin.
All of the faces start reciting Thatcher's
April 1986 speech on the bombing of Libya
in perfect unison.
You might watch it and think the woman's going
to choke based on how long the creature's
tongue is down her throat, but good ol' Laughy
comes in, and the studio audience goes nuts!
Laughy points out the cameras, says “You're
on Laugh is Fun!” and the woman starts laughing
too, with the creature's tongue still in her
mouth.
But I think my favorite prank I've ever seen
on Laugh is Fun was this one from season 37.
So, it's in a hospital.
There's a woman getting a c-section and all
the doctors are gathered around.
One of the doctors makes a comment on how
much hair the baby has, then he screams and
drops his surgical tools.
The rest of the team all start screaming as
well, and then- this is where it gets really
funny- you see Ryan Seacrest's head pop up
out from the woman.
This is causing her a lot of pain, obviously,
so she starts screaming and crying as the
Ryan Seacrest head fully emerges, at which
point you can tell that it's his head on an
octopus' body!
Classic bait-and-switch, right?
But that's not the end- the Ryan Seacrest
octopus starts singing 'Row Row Row Your Boat'
as it emerges, then three more octopi with
celebrities' heads come out of this woman.
There's one that looks like Jack Nicholson,
one that looks like Johnny Cash, and one who
looks like Martin Freeman, and when they've
all come out of her they start singing together
in four-part harmony.
It's hilarious!
Laughy walks in to point out the cameras,
and all the doctors start laughing.
Even the woman on the operating table is laughing.
In fact, she laughs so hard she passes out!
It's a real shame that there are never any
end credits because it would be so cool to
find out more about the people who make this
show.
I mean, they're total comedic geniuses, and
special effects wizards, too.
I couldn't even guess how they do some of
those pranks!
But sadly, there's very little information
about the show online, and you can't even
ask the victims of the pranks about it, because
all of them are dead.
What?
No, no, not because of Laugh is Fun!
That's just a prank show, it's all jokes.
They always show everyone laughing and perfectly
okay at the end, no matter how badly they
got mutilated in the episode.
You can even see some people who had been
on previous episodes among the studio audience
if you look hard enough!
But, by total coincidence, everyone who features
on Laugh is Fun eventually dies, or is already
dead, of totally unrelated causes.
Like the Turman family- the dad, Gary Turman,
was the one who had 18 extra heads grow out
of his neck.
Gary, his wife Lindsey, and their two kids
tragically passed away in a car wreck on the
28th of April, 1989.
Melissa and Travis Englund- the couple from
the squirrel prank went missing and were last
seen on the 12th of May, 1989.
The couple from the pigeon prank- Macey Gersham
and Kyle Parker- were both killed by a hit
and run driver in September of 2000.
Doris Carter, the woman from the Thatcher
prank, passed away from ovarian cancer in
1997, and Rebecca Nash, the woman who gave
birth to all those singing celebrity cephalopods,
died in childbirth in 2013.
You might think that last one had something
to do with her Laugh is Fun episode, due to
the hospital connection, but the surgeons
present when she died didn't report anything
strange happening at the time.
All of these deaths happen in roughly the
same years that all of these people had their
appearances on Laugh, but because it's only
available on streaming and video, it can't
really be said what the connection is since
there aren't air dates for any of the episodes.
While you might assume that these people died
after their appearances on Laugh, and the
show is actually some kind of death curse,
it's just as likely that they died before,
and Laugh is Fun is somehow filmed and distributed
from the great beyond.
Some people even think that the people who
film Laugh actually kidnap all the people
who appear on the show and fake their deaths
in some kind of big sinister conspiracy.
Sure, I have heard that all of the people
who supposedly 'died' after being on the show
have inconsistencies in their death records
and that many of their graves actually just
hold empty coffins, but still, that feels
totally unrealistic to me.
I mean, come on, can you really picture TV's
own Laughy Laugherson kidnapping anyone?
He has such a friendly attitude!
Like I said before, no information whatsoever
exists about the way this show is made.
Not even the SCP foundation has any answers
- they're still actively investigating the
ways in which people get chosen to be on Laugh
is Fun, as well as where it's filmed, and
who produces it.
Talk about a really niche cult hit!
I hope I've sold you on Laugh is Fun.
It may not be that well known, and you might
have trouble finding it, but trust me- it's
the funniest prank show you'll probably ever
watch.
I guarantee, once you get into it, it'll make
you laugh, and laugh, and laugh.
Laugh with us!
And hey, if you want to laugh with us in other
videos, check out “Robot Battle Royale SCP-1370
- Pesterbot” and “A Sea Snail's Fantasy
SCP-1867 - A Gentleman” for more of the
funnier side of the SCP Foundation!